you know products uh can sometimes get
built in a matter of months
uh but culture is built day by day over
years and
and decades and um i think it's really
important to take a long-term
approach to how we think about remote
work
mark zuckerberg here is discussing a
problem on the minds of many business
leaders
research shows that when employees leave
places with a high concentration of
specialized workers
innovation is stifled and as the
pandemic continues
more companies are letting workers move
far away from the office
sometimes permanently so why is
proximity important and what are
companies doing to adapt to their
decentralized workforces
over the decades tech companies like
apple tesla and facebook
opened offices in silicon valley
creating a hub of specialized tech
workers
business leaders and economists say that
this proximity is key to the success of
a new venture
research from the labor economist enrico
moretti suggests that when specialized
workers live near one another
their companies gain a competitive
advantage places like silicon valley
are very expensive because labor costs
more
office space cost more but they also
come with a lot of advantages and
especially if you are in the innovation
sector
there's a growing body of research that
points to the fact that
firms and inventors and innovators are
particularly productive and creative
in places like silicon valley in a
recent paper moretti traced the
migration patterns in patent filings of
more than 900 000
scientists inventors and engineers he
found that when a worker leaves an
industry specialized city
that worker innovates at a slower pace
in my data i'm following the same person
over time
i'm i'm seeing an innovator or inventor
in
rural ohio in cleveland you know in a
small place in the small classrooms and
i see how many patterns they they create
and then
i see that person moving to silicon
valley or xiaomi or boston
and what you see is that the same person
becomes
immediately significantly more
productive moretti says that on average
a worker in a city with many companies
in their field will produce better ideas
at a faster pace but during the pandemic
people have left tech clusters like san
francisco
some permanently companies say that some
employees want to be closer to their
hometowns and families
others are looking to save money though
the median price for a one bedroom
rental
fell in 2020 san francisco remains one
of the most expensive
metro areas in the u.s over recent years
that's led to a migration from the bay
to places like sacramento
las vegas and austin texas companies
have had to reimagine how they'll keep
innovating while their workforces
spread out when you try to measure where
innovation comes from
it's hard to force it it's hard to tell
people we're going to lock you in a room
and you're going to be innovative
for a decade laszlo bach led people
operations at google in 2017 he launched
his own company
humu humu develops products that
influence worker behavior
it's headquartered near alphabet's
campus in mountain view in my prior job
when i was at alphabet
we talked a lot about what we called
casual collisions or moments of
serendipity where people casually bump
into one another
so famously google news which is an
aggregator of websites
evolved because following the events of
september 11
there were two engineers standing in
line in a cafe one of them was
complaining about how it's hard to keep
up with all the news and the other said
i could pull something together
box says that these moments of
serendipity are the building blocks of
innovation
but they come most easily in person
bringing people physically together
and more importantly emotionally
together is vital
a prerequisite for innovation bach says
that innovation in the workplace
comes from low affinity distance
affinity distance is central to
innovation and productivity it's that
sense of closeness of connectivity
of psychological safety that allows
somebody to say i've got a crazy idea
i'm going to try that and the challenge
with remote work
is when you've been around people and
hung out with them and talked about
their kids and had water cooler
conversations
you get low affinity distance we get
closer to one another
some companies prefer to develop those
bonds in person
and others are leaning into the remote
experience there's a handful of
companies
that are saying we're just going to be a
remote forever we're going to hire
people wherever they want to be
and that's how it's going to be in the
short term companies are turning to
their own products to build community
facebook for example is adding workplace
friendly features to its portal video
conferencing product so we use our own
product our nudge engine
and it's great at finding those little
moments where people can actually
connect and be human and innovate humu's
nudge product
sends messages to employees at specific
times to encourage behaviors that boost
productivity
for example it might send a nudge that
suggests changing up weekly virtual team
bonding activities
by changing the prompt or the type of
event every
month or two or three months you refresh
the experience and you help bring people
together
other companies are cutting down on
avoidable meetings and designing
workflows that accommodate people who
live in different time zones
an example of this might be having a
really really clear problem statement in
a google document and a proposed
solution to that
and having multiple people being able to
weigh in on that document giving
comments on their own time
and then that being sufficient enough
for the uh
project leader to synthesize all that
information and make the
the next iteration of that proposed
solution dominique bayer
shapes the employee experience at
coinbase a san francisco tech company
that is now remote first
she says it's an opportunity to make the
workplace more efficient for people who
may have otherwise been marginalized
even if work environments had been
remote friendly before
remote first creates a more equitable
playing field to root out some of the
systemic disadvantages of not being
in the office when the majority of your
colleagues are in the office
at other companies like facebook
corporate offside gatherings could
invert
into on-sites for remote workers at
headquarters but alphabet for example
plans to have workers return to the
office when it's safe
surveys conducted by economists say that
after the pandemic about 25
of all full work days will be performed
from home
in the meantime companies will keep
revamping the remote experience